justice sheffield
pitched his first game against the
cleveland indians he was their
number one pick 31st overall back in
2014.
traded to the yankees july of 16
obtained fry
by the mariners in november of 18 from
the
yankees
two down for jose ramirez
hit hard right center field that is a
long way back
and off the top of the fence he'll go
into second base with a two out double
just missed his league leading 12 home
run of the year by maybe a foot or so
i'll tell you what that was all they
were
left a dent in the wall how many times
you see jose go to right center field
and this one almost got out of the
ballpark i don't think he has an
opposite field home run this year
no look at this it hits puts a dent in
the wall right there about a foot away
two at runner at second and one of the
bigger guys you're gonna see
in baseball friend mel reyes first
inning no score the
two pitch one guy on ground ball wide of
third to his right to backhand it is
crawford
the throw to first on a hop and it's in
time to get reyes
and that will retire the side mckenzie
this year this will be his six start
one-on-one record of 494
era and 23 and two thirds 22 walks a lot
of walks and a lot of strikeouts 34
strikeouts for him
breaking ball got him looking nice
little breaking ball there by tristan
there's mitch hannigan what a year that
first and home runs tied for seventh and
runs scored
fourth and total bases sixth in rbis and
fifth and extra base hits
and there's the drive deep to left and
the mariners have
a one nothing lead upper
tank mitch hannigan my goodness
number 12 rbi number 30.
and all you needed to hear was the
contact
i heard the same thing last night on the
home run that he hit
it was loud he likes the ball up in the
zone out of the entire lineup he
probably handles it better than most 89
miles an hour top of the strike zone and
drives it out of the ballpark
rivera will stand in the veteran
swinging a miss
that was a nasty slider in the dirt
rivera goes fishing after it comes up
empty that's the first punch out for
sheffield 2-2 from sheffield
swing and a miss struck him out two k's
for chef
ramirez doubled off the top of the right
field wall he went oppo
his first time up just missed a home run
yanks that one down the left field line
it's fair and into the corner it goes
jose's on his way to second base and
he'll pull in with a lead off double
he's two for two with two doubles
and the indians once again will have a
scoring opportunity
and now for animal reyes 3-2 pitcher to
reyes runner at second
reyes they tag him did they get him
yeah they say he tagged him dropped it
on the exchange
yeah i think angel because he ran in
onto the grass called him out for
leaving the baseline yeah there it is
that's what he was saying right there at
the start of it he was waving it because
he just came out of the line and
went too far once he was out on the
grass and run on its second
reyes go ahead run out at first base
rosario
and again the 1-2 pitch to josh naylor
swinging a ground ball
squibs past the mound out near second up
with the ball crawford he's got it right
at the back steps on the pillow for the
out on rosario
coming down the line and that'll end the
inning and sheffield
gets out of trouble here in the fourth
so runners at first and second
and that'll bring up second baseman
dylan moore
high fly ball headed towards the pin
it's got kerry
giddy up gone three run over dylan moore
and america's have a four
lead here in the fourth for demo his
fifth home run
takes his rbi total to 19.
boy did he drag that one out on a 2-2
pitch he's getting hot he's been
swinging the bat well for a week now
i think that was the slider let's take a
look at it 86 miles an hour yep that's
it just kind of spinning in the middle
of the plate
409 feet exit v-low of 105.
one out base is loaded marmo could bust
this game wide open
[Applause]
not particularly deep henniger tags
rosario
here's the throw here comes hannah the
throw away he's in there
rivera could not handle it but marmal
gets the job done with the sac fly
mariners have a five nothing lead
rbi from marmalayos his ninth
well here you go it wasn't deep panicker
has good speed this is a strong throw
in fact they would have had him if he'd
been able to pick it cleanly oh man
yeah give him a little bit of a better
hop
umpire ended up blocking it
[Applause]
jose ramirez is two for two and has
doubled both times up
there's a line driving the left center
that's going to be a base hit
luplow on his way to third ramirez is
going to go to second and he's in there
safely oh
the door is cracked open now well
that's just great hustle on jose's part
to get himself in
scoring for this because he saw they
were going to third and you know how he
runs the bases he turns it like it's
going to be another double
but he reads the throw coming in going
to third base and that enabled him once
he saw luplow go
he's just going to he never missed but
hey we'll take it
here's friedman reyes and a weak tapper
that'll get a run home see that's where
the big man's got to be a little more
patient on the first pitch you got
second and third
and you know a little hey you get him in
yeah ground ball gets him in but he's a
guy that could have done a lot more
damage and now we'll see if eddie
rosario can pick him up
get that run home from third
[Applause]
tops it that'll get another run home and
a close play at first but they just do
get the out two down but another run
scores on the play as ramirez comes down
the line from
third kel nixon but tonight oh for three
struck out twice against
tristan mckenzie call strike three on
the outside corner fastball
and the side is retired so two on and
two outs
and the banner will be designated hitter
donovan walton
and there's another one down the line
marmos going to score
jp's in full flight he'll score easily
donovan walton thinking three
no throw a two-run triple vernon
7-2 harold ramirez the batter he's one
for
three harold ramirez rocking one into
the bullpen
his first home run as a cleveland indian
[Applause]
makes it a 7-3 ball game so rosario on
it first with two down and here's
eu chang to chang
and he got him there's your bug in
mariners win it
7-3